whether you're a fast and furious fan
who needs a refresher on how Tom went
from living his life a quarter mile at a
time to thwarting acts of terrorism or
someone who has never watched the fast
film but he's curious to learn more
about the franchise's central character
we've got you covered
Dominic was one of three Toretto
children that we know of
alongside his sister Mia and brother
Jacob he grew up in Los Angeles where
his family owned and operated Toretto's
market and cafe while his father also
worked as a professional stock car
driver along with his love of cars Dom
also inherited his father's religious
faith and devotion to friends and family
when Dom was young he helped his father
rebuild a 1970 Dodge Charger r/t which
he would continue to drive and cherish
well into adulthood in my dad built a
500 horse it's a Detroit muscle
at some point Dom's father was killed
during a race after being run off the
track by a driver named Kenny Linder Dom
witnessed the accident which killed his
father instantly and traumatized young
Dom a week after his father died Dom
assaulted Linder which ended Linder's
racing career and sent Dom to prison for
two years even after he was released Dom
couldn't follow in his father's
footsteps since he received a lifetime
ban from the racetracks following the
attack DOM and Letty Ortiz met when they
were children around the time Letty was
10 years old and formed a friendship
around their shared love of cars as
teenagers they began dating and remained
together until the first Fast & Furious
film Letty worked with Dom stealing DVD
players and other high-end electronics
and also participated in his illegal
nighttime street races by the end of
that film DOM and Letty have to split up
when the police are made aware of Dom's
criminal activities and he's forced to
go on the run after spending some time
apart the two get back together in the
los bandoleros short film which finds
Letty tracking DOM down in the Dominican
Republic
the couple immediately rekindles their
romance ends secretly marries before the
events of the fourth movie however
shortly after their wedding Dom winds up
leaving Letty in order to protect her
since the police are after him again
following his latest heist while they're
apart he receives some devastating news
he's been murdered in the first Fast and
the Furious film Dominic Toretto and LA
police officer Brian O'Conner are on
opposite sides of the law
DOM and Brian first crossed paths when
Brian goes undercover to investigate a
group that's stealing electronics out of
18 wheelers at first Dom is wary of
Brian but he eventually warms up to him
after Brian helps him evade the police
meanwhile Brian is still maintaining it
carefully-crafted persona engineered the
gang Dom's trust so he can arrest him
however Brian genuinely likes Tom as
well as his sister Mia and finds himself
increasingly conflicted the deeper he
gets into his investigation eventually
Brian blows his whole cover in order to
get medical help for a member of Dom's
crew who's seriously injured yeah this
is officer Brian O'Conner
I'm off-duty MAPD life might pull out
right away
betrayed dog tries to evade the police
but in the process wrecks his car and
resigns himself to being arrested
Brian realizes that he can't bring
himself to arrest on him and instead
gives him the keys to his own car
allowing Dom to escape at first DOM and
Brian don't keep in touch and Brian
remains a police officer but by the end
of the fourth film Brian finally cuts
ties with the law in order to break Dom
out of prison Joanne once and for all
that he considers Dom family Dom tells
Brian in the Fast and the Furious that
he would rather die than return to
prison but that isn't enough to dissuade
Dom from engaging in criminal activities
after the first fast film Dom graduates
from stealing electronics to stealing
tankers full of fuel and in Fast and
Furious he kills the man responsible for
Letty's death by ramming him with a car
although Brian advocates hard for
clemency for da master he helps him
capture a notorious drug dealer Dom is
arrested and sentenced to 25 years to
life in prison without the possibility
of early parole
before he can serve any of his sentence
Brian and Mia along with two of Dom's
friends chased down the prison bus
transporting DOM and break him out
afterward Dom flees the country and
commits various heists culminating in
the spectacularly dramatic robbery of a
drug lord who had attempted to extort
him this causes him to be pursued by
Luke Hobbs who later enlists Tom's help
in apprehending the terrorist Owen Shaw
in exchange Hobbs arranges for Dom's
criminal record to be expunged allowing
him to return to the United States Dom
means police officer Elena nevas during
the events of Fast Five during when she
works alongside Hobbes two opposed
and his crew but early in the film Dom
saves Elena from the drug lords men
which begins to change her opinion of
him by the end of the film Elaine on
hobbs have joined forces with Dom
against their common foe after Dom saves
them on several occasions later Hobbs
decides to give Tom and his crew a
24-hour head start before he begins
chasing them as thanks for all of Dom's
help however rather than remain in Rio
as a police officer Elena chooses to
follow Tom to Spain where the two of
them begin a romantic relationship at
the beginning of Fast & Furious 6
they're still together living together
on the Canary Islands but when Dom
discovers that Letty is still alive
Elena graciously bhau's out of the
relationship
allowing Dom to returned to Letty with a
clear conscience in Fast & Furious 6 Tom
learns that Letty is alive but suffering
from amnesia it turns out Letty survived
the accident that supposedly killed her
but lost her memory when Owen Shaw went
to the hospital to kill her he changed
his mind and brought her into his crew
instead knowing Tom will do anything for
Letty Hobbes asked for his assistance
apprehending Shaw in exchange for a full
pardon Everest Letty has no memory of
Dom and doesn't hesitate to work against
him but when Dom risks his life to save
her it sparks a dim flicker of
recognition she eventually switches
sides to help Dom even though she still
doesn't remember him she stays with Dom
at the end of fast and furious 6 and
continues working with DOM and his crew
throughout furious 7 eventually Letty
gets her memories back during Furious 7
at which point she remembers her wedding
to Dom DOM and Letty finally take their
long-overdue honeymoon it's beginning to
fade at a furious although like most
things in DOM and Lettie's relationship
it doesn't exactly go according to plan
after breaking Dom out of prison Brian
can't go back to being a police officer
or an FBI agent and instead joins DOM
and Mia in their criminal activities he
functions as Dom's right-hand man during
several heists and the two grow closer
the longer they work together
simultaneously Brian's relationship with
Mia deepens and she eventually becomes
pregnant by the end of past five Dom is
thrilled to become an uncle to baby jack
and comes to think of Brian as his
brother during the filming of Furious 7
actor Paul Walker was tragically killed
in a car accident initially been diesel
and the rest of the fast crew considered
shutting down production on the film
since many of them were close to Walker
especially diesel instead they decided
that the best way to honor Walker was to
give Brian the happy end
he deserved the ending the Furious 7 was
rewritten to get Brian O'Connor a
peaceful exit from the franchise
allowing him to retire from his life of
crime to raise his children Mia
although Brian is alive and well in the
Fast & Furious movies he's often talked
about as someone who is deeply and
profoundly missed subtly breaking the
fourth wall so the films can acknowledge
the painful loss of Walker while still
allowing Brian to live on but he'll
always be with me change the game with
and you'll always be my brother well no
one in the past films has been as close
to DOM as Brian or Letty he's always
surrounded himself with close friends
that he refers to as his family while
the cast of secondary characters Thomas
surrounded himself with fluctuates for
the first few films he now has a core
group of associates he relies on for
pretty much every mission he goes on
each with their own particular skillset
Roman Pearce was actually Brian's friend
first and was roped into his first fast
escapades during the events of too fast
too furious Bryan later enlisted him to
help with a heist in Fast Five counting
his ability to talk himself out of any
situation and he's been an integral part
of Dom's crew ever since acting as a
counterpart to Roman is tej Parker a
skilled hacker and engineer who also
made his first appearance in the second
film but officially joined in the fifth
the most recent addition to the crew is
Ramsey a hacker and innovator who joined
the crew in Furious 7 Luke Hobbs has
also been a regular member of Dom's crew
since Fast Five but they've since gone
their separate ways mostly so Hobbes can
spin off into his own franchise
Dom's crew also occasionally includes
his friends Leo and Santos although they
don't appear to be as close to DOM as
the others being a part of Dominic
Toretto's family is not without risks
and several of Dom's associates have
lost their lives as a result of their
association with him the first of all
was Jessie who worked in Dom's auto shop
in The Fast and the Furious and was
killed in a drive-by shooting next to go
was Vince Dom's childhood friend who was
part of Dom's crew in the first film
then dropped off the grid for a while
before returning in the fifth pill
Vince resented Brian for his influence
in Toms life but cared about Dom enough
to name his son after him Vince was
killed during an effort to save Luke
hops then there are the losses that had
an even larger impact on Tom and the
rest of his crew Gisele Yashar initially
worked for an opponent of Dom's in the
fourth film but wound up switching sides
when Tom showed that he valued her life
more than her employer
han Solo met Dom in Mexico between the
first and fourth films and worked
closely with him ever since
Honda Gisele got together in Fast Five
but she sacrificed herself to save Han
in Fast & Furious 6
grieving han moved to Tokyo where he was
run off the road and supposedly killed
by Owens brother Deckard Shaw in the
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift the
loss upon motivated Dom through the
events of Furious 7 but as the trailers
for f9 have revealed han is
he's still alive somehow it's easy to
wonder how a franchise that started out
with small-scale electronic heist has
somehow graduated to nuclear terrorism
the truth is that the shift wasn't all
that gradual in the first film dominus
crew were stealing DVD players and
running an illegal street-racing ring
too fast too furious and Tokyo Drift
both follow characters other than Dom
but by the fourth film although Dom's
targets have gotten bigger he's still
largely pulling the same sorts of heists
a fuel tanker is much bigger than a DVD
player but it's still executed in much
the same way as his earlier schemes then
in Fast Five the whole franchise pivots
in the extreme when dominus crew go from
stealing cars to planning an elaborate
high-speed heist to steal an entire bank
vault in the film this is motivated
mostly by revenge but practically it was
an effective way of rejuvenating the
franchise by adding more ridiculous
action and high-energy fun from there
Dom's team quickly morphs from petty
thieves into an elite mercenary squad
that keeps getting hired to take down
increasingly ambitious and diabolical
baddies does it make real-world sense no
but in the Fast and the Furious
Universit somehow works at the beginning
of the fate of the Furious Tom is
ambushed on his honeymoon by a terrorist
named cypher who forces him to a sister
and her plan to start a nuclear war
pitting him against his own crew it's
hard to imagine anything that would
cause Dom to betray his family but
cypher finds the one thing that Tom
would cherish even more than his chosen
family his infant son it turns out that
when Dom found out Letty was alive and
Elena stepped away from their
relationship she was actually pregnant
she wound up giving birth to a son off
screen and the two were subsequently
kidnapped by cypher to use as leverage
over Dom Elena hadn't given her son a
first name yet referring to him only by
his middle name Marcos so Dom could
choose his first name cipher execute
Elena as punishment went on allows Letty
to escape but he ultimately manages to
save his son whom he commits the raising
with Letty at the end of the fate of the
Furious Tom introduces his son to his
crew by his new name everyone
meet Brian dom has faced a number of
opponents throughout his fast and
furious adventures ranging from
small-scale crooks to full-on
supervillains in the first film Johnny
Tran runs a rival street racing gang in
LA which seems almost cute compared to
the antagonist Dom has gone up against
since Fast and Furious brings a drug
lord Arturo Braga who arranges for the
death of Letty and works with the Shaw
brothers but is supposedly still in
prison going into f9 Hernan Reyes is the
drug lord Dom's crew robbed at the end
of Fast Five killed at the end of that
film by Luke Hobbs the sixth film sees
Dom facing off against Owen Shaw and
then in the seventh film he goes
head-to-head with Owens brother Decker
however despite both Shaw Brothers
attempting to execute some pretty nasty
schemes and even attempting to kill a
member of Dom's crew they're now on more
or less friendly terms with Tom as they
both helped rescue his son from cyber
and the fate of the Furious cypher on
the other hand remains not only free but
still intent on causing a nuclear war
and if the trailers for app 9 or any
indication determined to kill Tom in the
process check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stop or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]